this week is going to be a bit different
because it's not going to be the useful
daily Bitcoin update I don't know guys
if you remember the an alcohol market
update that I posted three weeks ago so
well this is going to be the second part
so we're gonna talk about many different
charts we're going to talk about of
course Bitcoin the Bitcoin dominance
total free total free versus Bitcoin
um a lot of article so when I go through
the 12 altcoins that I talked about in
the previous video
we're going to see how they are doing
and we want to update about them and of
course a new selection of 10 new
altcoins okay the are not in that
previous video so get yourself a drink
and relax because this video is gonna
probably take a while so the first thing
of course has to be Bitcoin because uh
do you guys know that it's pointless if
I start to chart an alcohol without
charting Bitcoin previously because the
outcome Market also follows Bitcoin of
course there are some exceptions
of alcohols that move at their will okay
usually new altcoins but uh generally
speaking the alcohol Market always
follows Bitcoin okay so when I posted
that video three weeks ago I remember
that we were in this one okay yeah the
time that was around the 30th of July so
yeah the time makes sense three four
weeks ago and I was telling you guys
that I was quite bad this year for the
simple fact that we were in this range
and then we saw a deviation above the
range Heist remember that I was telling
you guys that I was taking a short here
and I did as soon as we go back into the
range and confirm the deviation and we
were testing the rain's highest
resistance and then we broke out
from the range to the downside because
that is usually what happens when you
see the deviation in one of the ends of
the range okay then you usually see a
breakout in the other end that usually
what happens so we were respecting that
also in the daily time frame we were
testing the 50 meters resistance and
also the range lows so it was not
looking great and
eventually we dropped okay we were
talking about two potential supports one
of them was this one okay because we so
here the price got rejected twice and we
saw two big sell-offs so that song could
be tested as support
so I was telling you guys to not open
any Longs here but wait for deviation
and then if we go back above it then you
could open along there at this point
here because otherwise you would see
Bitcoin falling lower to the range lows
and that's where we are right now at
okay check that out so we are right now
in the
exact place okay and now it's likely in
my opinion remember that of course there
is no Financial advice I'm just telling
you my opinion it's likely that maybe we
see some more range in here I don't care
okay this range but in the midterm
we're expecting more downside why
because if we go to the weekly time
frame
you can see that we've just lost the
weekly 50ma and that is usually not a
good sign all right so you know again we
might see some more range in here for
quite some time but where eventually is
pectin a drop below this range lows and
we are targeting the 50 of this week
and that's around twenty thousand five
hundred okay uh you also have here a
liquidity pool
that will be your Target around 22k but
because we have a week a long week right
below it I'm targeting 50 of the week
instead okay around 20 700 ish so that's
what I think now
if the alcohol Market follows Bitcoin
a Bitcoin drops then altcoins should
also drop right uh but we have also
another problem and is that if we check
the Bitcoin dominance
we were talking also about this chart
for quite some time
remember that we were in this range for
uh two years you can see that we started
here in right at the start of May 2021
and we also broke out from the rains in
May 2023 so that's exactly a 2dr range
and when we're at this point I was
telling you guys that it was very likely
that we saw a broke out was 52 53
percent
actually go to 52 percent and then we'll
use when we started to go rejected here
at this projection I was telling you
that it was also likely now
that we came again to this previous
resistance Zone to test their support
and I think that that's what we are
right now uh you might see some people
saying that the Bitcoin dominance is
looking very simple if you put in the
bigger picture I think that we are only
just testing this previous 2D resistance
as support okay if we fall from here
then
uh I think in my opinion would be
because Bitcoin is dropping also which
it would be bad for alcoons I personally
don't see at this point the Bitcoin
dominance dropping back inside the range
without Bitcoin dropping so I think if
the Bitcoin dominance gets back into the
ranges because Bitcoin is also dropping
but now for a second think about this
scenario of Bitcoin holding and the
Bitcoin dominance having another leg up
I think that's more likely or even more
likely
and more dangerous is if Bitcoin drops
and the Bitcoin dominance holds the
sonar support because if that happens if
Bitcoin is dropping towards 20K and the
Bitcoin dominance is still in this Zone
between 49 and 48 then altcoins Are
Gonna Get Wrecked so in my opinion that
scenario of Bitcoin holding on the
outcome Market recovering this soon
again
that's more likely
or also again if Bitcoin drops
um the Bitcoin dominance also drops that
is more likely the Bitcoin doing good
like for example Bitcoin holding or
going up and the Bitcoin dominance
dropping because that would be another
season and I'm not calling another
season
and you guys know me
since all this time I haven't called for
a single old season because uh I'm I'm
honest with you and when we were at this
point I was telling you don't listen to
the seasons because those schools are
not making sense at the moment because
usually when you come to this resistance
you see maybe a spike you drop a spike
you drop a spike you drop again and
again and here you were not saying the
same if you notice you kept seeing
sorry
here many candles testing the resistance
but we were not dropping we were just
consolidating before
a leg higher okay and now we're testing
a support in my opinion
so again the Bitcoin dominance I don't
think is looking bearish I think in fact
it's looking pretty good if it drops on
here it'll be because Bitcoin is also
dropping hard Okay so
I'm I'll remain bullish in the Bitcoin
dominance at the moment even if we just
had a three percent drop because that's
normal you know in higher time frame it
might look like a three percent drop but
you're only testing this preview
resistance support that's all now if you
go to the total free
the 2003 a total market cap of altcoins
and stable coins so here you don't have
uh neither Bitcoin or ethereum it's only
again altcoins and stable coins
you see here
and I talked about this in the previous
video that in my opinion this chart is
also bearish
why because we are making lower highs
constantly okay it's all the time lower
highs let me remove this for you okay if
you check this that's a high but this
one is lower
but this one is lower
um let me check I'm pretty sure it's
lower yep that's low because that's the
high
okay so you are making all the time
lower highs constantly okay
constantly
and I don't know what's gonna happen
here but if we keep making lower highs
and we have also these two liquidity
pools okay we have one here and we have
one here this one's around liquidity
pools because they are getting three
traced by weeks
okay so those ones don't count but these
two do then you have here this space
that that you could go to and that would
be really bad for the altcoins because
altcoins are basically in this chart the
exceptions are also in this chart so if
you're telling me Oh Pepe when Pepe was
going up it was also in this chart okay
everything the whole altcoin market and
the stable coin Market is in this chart
okay so personally
um I don't know guys but you know you
have this low
do you see lower highs so it's likely
that this you know comes towards this
zone or at least that's what I'm
expecting okay that we
that we drop below this 300 billion
dollars soon towards the 230 or 200
10 billion dollars soon okay
that's why I'm existing for the total
free and of course
uh geralt coins are gonna follow all
right now if you go to the total free
versus Bitcoin
all right then
we have here also my opinion quad
various chart you can see a lot of hits
to the upside about price couldn't break
Above This zone so at the end you had
here a Bart Simpson pattern okay
and and now in for what I see okay is
that we continuously are making lower
highs and lower lows okay so the chart
is looking something like this uh I
don't know I think that it's very likely
that we come to test this support Zone
over here and if we fall
from here then you have another support
so uh this is also not a song where I'm
what I want to buy I want to buy more
in this Zone over here this also a chart
that I'm using to consider when to
change my Bitcoin for altcoins okay so
that's what I think I think that list
will come towards this Support over here
at 0.50
right now we're at 0.64. now let's go to
the altcoins that we were talking about
let's go to chain link for example
okay
chain link we said that we were inside
this range we talked about this
deviation do you guys remember I did a
bit only for chain link so I think it
was three months ago or two months ago
we came to this um deviation then we saw
the pump and then when I posted the
video three weeks ago so we were then in
this one over here I was telling you I
was very likely that we revisit the low
second and if you notice we've just
tested the rain slows again
okay so I don't know what's going to
happen with the alt concept for example
chain link that are holding a range for
so long
what I'm expecting the 2013 continues to
continue dropping I just think that
you know
uh I mean this range is good I like I
like when we see this type of range but
I do think that it's also likely that we
might see even lower prices okay maybe
something like this okay but if I'm
honest with you I don't really know
what's going to happen to if I'm
expecting a drop in the 2003 and in the
altcoin market I don't know what's going
to happen with this Alcon star in a
Range okay because yes this accumulation
ranges are great that's really good
because I still didn't do that yes if
where are the lows and we are ranging
that means that you know there is
probably going to be a breakout from
here and we want to have a good Zone to
to consolidate and buy but
thinking that we're going to have a new
outcome drop I only see uh two scenarios
either that chain link tries to recover
now so when we dump then it Dooms again
to the range lows and at the end we keep
ranging here and consolidating here or
if chaining is still at the range slows
and is looking weak when we have the
next drop in the alkyl market then we're
also going to make an a new low so let's
see what happens with chain link also
having here at the weekly 50ma you know
we just tested that as resistance here
and here
um I wouldn't be surprised honestly if
we continue making lower lows and we and
we have a new low that wouldn't surprise
me at all it's true that here you have
an important
Support over there
you can see there okay so other motion
to happen guys but maybe you can see
some form of deviation here
okay
and then you can get back into the range
and finally go higher so that's what I'm
looking for chaining
um quite scared to buy here
in my opinion again you could buy here
if you want it okay and then DCA
in case we have a new low but uh at the
moment I have so many outcomes that I'm
looking at I'm still doing my research
so I prefer to wait for now okay if I
have to buy higher once you have this
confirmation of this pump above the 50
EMA in the weekly time frame test your
support then I'll buy the confirmation
or miss out okay but I think I'm gonna
favor that is likely that we make a new
look for chain link okay again maybe a
deviation below this potential Support
over here okay something like that so
that's that's my new update for chain
link
now if we check Solana
let's check Solana uh for Solana we were
I think let me go back over 30th of
April so we're wearing this Zone over
here and we were also talking about
potential drop again to this to this uh
soon over here okay around 14 and of
course if you lose if you fall
below this Zone okay then you can Target
these levels okay this liquidity pool
and this week but um I don't even want
to go again to eight dollars I do really
believe that we're gonna see 14 again uh
I think that's very likely and in fact I
think that's the most likely scenario
that we see 14 and then from there let's
see what happens again we go level by
level support by support so if we fall
below 14 then the next Zone that I'm
targeting is this liquidity pool around
ten dollars okay uh that's my
uh follow-up update for Solana then for
op
let's check op
okay
for op we were talking about the
possibility let me go to the Daily time
frame instead
of what we're talking about this trend
line over here
okay but we're also talking about
deviation Above This level
and you see it actually happened
perfectly in fact okay you get Aviation
to 183
and then you saw a drop now we are back
inside this range over here
okay but I do think that in the midterm
we're gonna continue dropping so let me
remove this dot edit that I think we're
going to continue dropping why because
we have here some weeks unfilled that I
think they're gonna get filled at some
point so uh once we have some daily
candles below the range lows the same as
we did with Bitcoin then I think that'll
be the time to short again op
towards this level over here then if you
lose this level they're gonna have also
this level over here and if you lose
this level you have also the 50 of this
week okay so those are the targets for
op I think that at least in my opinion
it's likely that we come to this second
week around 1.15 so that's what I'm
targeting at the moment all right
um that's the song that I'm planning to
potentially buy for a spot but also
again if we get these that I'm asking
these daily candles below the range lows
then I'm also gonna take this as a swing
short okay so I hope that's clear guys
let's continue with some articles that
were in that previous video Matic
let's check Matic
what with Matik I've been pretty clear
is this mymatic chart
um that's my magic chart with Matic has
been pretty clear because we have this
liquidity pool
from here
okay that was the first one that we were
expecting price to go and I've been
calling that since we were around one
dollar okay and then you saw that drop
then you had this train line over here
and in that video three weeks ago I was
telling you that you know having this
train line it was very likely that we
broke below this train land because
usually when you see the string and
there is a lot of liquidity
in this song okay so it was very likely
to drop again below this rail line and
go to the Daily community pool again but
ultimate 4matic
if we go into higher time frame weekly
time frame
I think this is going to continue the
open if I'm honest with you I think this
is going to continue dropping I think
that it's very likely that we come again
to this song
and that will be around 0 to 40. but if
we actually did Beethoven from this lows
I do think that the ultimate level for
Matic that can't drop too okay I don't
again I don't think we're gonna drop
below this one but I think there is a
chance that we come to this one
that will be 0.25 ish okay and I know it
sounds a bit crazy because we're at 0.50
but
how much of a drop is this
that's around uh 50 50 something percent
drop okay now if you check from here
from my call of around one dollar
today
50 and already happened anima half
sounded crazy and it happened so again I
do think that it's very likely that we
come
and that one is probably about 35 drop
about a 30 drop and then if you lose
this soon
okay then we're gonna come
to watch this liquidity pool over here
that's what I think
so know a place that I want to buy Matic
right now
okay I'm prefer to wait here also uh I
don't know if I'm gonna end the buying
Matic that's something that I haven't
decided yet but anyway this is not the
song that I would like to buy Matic for
the long term I think we're gonna go
lower and it's quite important I mean
you can start to disable if you want
I'm not trying to tell you to to try and
time the bottom because
that's very hard but if you keep doing
DCA okay so if you bought for example
you know art here R1 okay of view in
this drop here also at 0 to 80 or at
0.50 and then you drop again to 0.40 and
again to 0.25 then your average it's
empty it's gonna be at 0.66 or 0.70.
it's gonna be in this zone so you're
gonna need to wait four months for a
price to go to break even all right so
that's what I'm telling you guys be
patient I think that
Matic is very likely to drop at least to
0.40 if I'm honest with you let's
continue
avax
or a box
Spanish accent detected well a box
wow okay I didn't check this chart for
quite some time
but we just made a new low
nice we've just made halfway done that
new low today
let me check
um no it wasn't today it was a couple
days ago okay but we made a new low and
we were talking about a box
saying that it's a cone dice looking
very weak okay um to me this is the
perfect definition of the current
alcohol Market
if you take a box versus Bitcoin
what do you see here
look I actually have drawn this this uh
arrows over here we keep making lower
highs all the time okay all the time
lower highs so it's likely that price
comes again towards this Zone you have
in here you know quite a big liquidity
pool in fact so you know the only reason
why a box didn't drop before in the
dollar pair is because Bitcoin data
times two this year okay but now the
Bitcoin is dropping is when a box it can
do
a new looks okay
um these are the labels for a box I'm
still gonna stick to these levels I
think they're pretty good
I think this one is going to be taken
soon to be honest 9.50 but notice that
we were around 14 when I posted a video
now we're at 10. so I'm telling you guys
you just need to be patient okay so if
you didn't watch the video again if you
drop below 9.50
dropping then I believe I want to see
seven dollars next all right so that's
uh another date for a box now Paul cadot
let me see okay we haven't made a new
looks yet
we can see that we are holding
Above This support right now but again
when you see a support like this holding
by the way this is making again
lower highs all the time
okay
this is making lower high so maybe you
see now another pump but it should be uh
again a new lower high from here and
then I do think that eventually we're
gonna come to this one over here around
3.50 so Paul card
update same same projection in my
opinion now if we go to rows
let's check Rose
oh wow look Rose has already hit our
zones if you notice okay so
we'll wait around here
okay and you were saying that it was
very likely that we came again to the
range lows or even lower to the range
well below the range okay
um this is not looking great
this chart is not looking great because
it seems that we have blocked out from
the range lows and we're testing and
resistance so you might even see lower
lower annual low here okay we might
print a lower low here
so Rose is not looking great because
if it has already made
uh this drop from here
okay and we haven't held higher and then
maybe imagine that in some weeks or in a
couple of months we see a new drop in
the alcohol Market
and we're reading this song that is very
likely that we're making love so uh Rose
is not coming that I would touch right
now if I'm honest with you
okay and with near
uh wow
wow
same okay uh we've just made a new low
for what I can see we've just made a new
low and he also hit or potential bison
over here
so
again it's not great okay because
if it's already looking weak before the
next drop in the alcohol Market
what is that gonna take this coin uh I
was telling you that I didn't think that
it was gonna go below one dollar it
still hasn't gone below one dollar even
to one dollar zero two that's at 118. so
let's see what it does okay I would like
to see to be honest near pumping
okay I get to my strength before that
new drop that we might see okay because
otherwise this is gonna make new lows
all right so Nia is not another coin
that I would touch again if we reclaim
these range flows test it as support
then you can open along here okay
um then you can even compound here but
for long term
honestly if you are into DCA right now I
wouldn't touch it because uh it's
looking at the moment pretty weak okay
let's continue
tala
okay for what I can see I think I just
hit also a level that I was talking
about that was the 50 of this week yep
indeed and as you can see that is
consolidating here but if we go into the
weekly time frame
the chart is not looking great it's it's
true the it's in my opinion a high risk
High reward chart because it's quite
risky to put money into this chart when
it has dropped a
90 98 this coin has really dropped okay
um
and it's looking still pretty weak I
think
we're probably gonna come to this degree
to pull over here
and that would be
let me Mark this for you
0.16.5 okay and that drop is another
15 drop I don't know if you guys if I
want to make new lows with this coin the
chart is not looking great in my opinion
so this is a coin that I wouldn't touch
just yet so when I'm probably gonna
continue updating about this coin
because again like just imagine if you
buy for example here
and this prompts to
um I don't know this one for example
that's a times 20. I mean it's quite
tasty but again the chart is not looking
it's not looking right yet now let's
continue with Dutch
so Lotus is still in this consolidation
range between the two yellow bars and
the orange line is the song where we
were talking about the possibility that
Dutch came to get maybe even DV8 here
and that would be a potential good bison
okay but still it has some uh room to
drop when we made the video about eight
cents we're at six now we came even into
five both from his is still another 20
drop okay uh which I think that I'll
come
now if you go to the next one fit
this a coin that I actually uh find
quite interesting
and I actually like this is one of the
one style Pro UI
um I was talking about the idea that we
had this straight lines over here and we
had also this pump quite aggressive pump
in January March
now between in actually in general it
was
and we were also talking about the idea
that I was very likely that we came to
test this train line and also this
Support over here and some people go
offended
so people go offended with this chart
but if I'm honest with you
30th of aprilish over around well at the
same level as now but you can see that
he made also a new low
okay that's a new low and also let me
tell you something this chart is making
lower lows on Lower highs it's clearing
a downtrend check this out you have here
a high hello then you have a lower high
a lower low you have here another lower
high and the lower low what's next guys
what is probably going to be another
lower lower high and a new lower low
until eventually will come to the worst
this level
all right so it's not looking great uh I
think
that I don't even want to go all the way
to 11 cents let me check again
into the weekly time frame
um it might not be 11 cents aside
Marquia it might be a bit higher like
maybe 12 bro I still think that this is
when I drop is still quite a lot okay
and we're talking about maybe a 50 drop
I think it's quite likely to be honest
with you guys so this is one of the
coins that I'm actually uh researching
because I think it's a potential a good
project to buy for the long term
this channel is not promoted by any coin
I'm not promoting anything I don't have
any back or fetch at the moment so I'm
not trying to pump it okay I'm just
telling you that uh I'm still expecting
maybe a 50 drop towards uh 11 cents and
I'm probably gonna buy if you get this
drop okay for the long term because I
think that this coin can uh of course
break uh they are the highest at one
dollar and probably go to three four
dollars slightly okay so this is one of
the projects that you might do at times
20 times 25 in the next Bull Run if they
do the things right uh but again I might
talk about artificial intelligence coins
in the next video let's continue uh
there was only one more coin to update
from the previous video okay and that's
Balkan Forge this coin is in a Range as
you can see and the last time that I
talked about this this code this token
was uh the idea of a deviation hang on
let me change the color to hello
the idea of a deviation below the range
lows okay sorry something like this
all right and that will take you to
maybe 2.50 ish all right below below
three for sure so I'm looking to buy
this between 2.50 maybe go to come even
know what to do 50 two dollars something
like that okay in this one I think that
would be a good buy soon for this
project
and that is everything guys let's that's
the update of the previous 12 altcoins
that I that I talked about and I want to
talk about 10 new altcoins again it's
not 10
new altcoins
in the market okay they are well known I
mean 10 urquins in this Channel that I
didn't mentioned before so the first one
is Phantom
let's check Phantom
uh no that's not the chart that I like
uh I think that I like
this one
yep
um well I don't have anything but
basically pretty much it looks the same
as the total three okay
um I think that we're in this
accumulation range but since I'm
expecting a new drop in the altcoin
market in 2003 then I think that Phantom
is probably gonna make a new uh a new
low if I'm honest with you maybe a
deviation here below this range lows
okay then consolidate even more and then
you can see here the breakout to the
upside uh probably uh as I mentioned in
previous videos by looking at the Cycles
we have a Halloween every four years and
usually the year of the Halloween that's
when the bull market starts it usually
is two three months after the Halloween
so if the next album is going to happen
in Spring 2024 then uh probably will see
a new uh Bull Run according to the to
the cycle
um in summer 2024 maybe in August uh
something like that okay but remember
that if you support the idea you should
also support the idea that
the second part of H pre-half engineer
it's quite bearish so uh it wouldn't
surprise me to see a new low printing in
Phantom maybe it's 0.15 0.14 okay and
that would be another 30 30 drop for
this coin okay
so that's what I think of phantom I'm
not saying that I'm buying or not I'm
still doing my research book uh this is
not a song what I would buy I think it's
gonna go uh even lower now if you go to
xrp
let's see what xrp is doing
I think I have this this chart
uh hang on
some of you will remember this chart
because when we saw this pump when
Ripple won the the court case against
the SEC then everybody got euphoric and
xrp pumps it upside is normal it's also
quite a normal I need to hear my friend
at least that when this coin pumps this
hard bad things come in the next days
and so we did look at that okay that's
some kind of an exit liquidity boom okay
now you are again back inside the range
a studio Hall in the 50 em in the weekly
time frame but I do think that it's very
likely that we come again to the
mid-range here
that's around 0.40 okay and if we hold
here because I believe that this coin uh
it's quite strong so it's okay that we
hold up here then uh this might be
there's we might see some consolidation
again here if you lose this mid-range
then as in every range you would be
targeting the range loss okay uh I don't
know if you'll arrive there if we get
there okay again to 0 30 but I do think
that we're gonna probably get again to
0.40. uh that's what I think but for now
I I wouldn't I wouldn't open any shots
because where above the weekly 50ma
right so just looking from um uh long
term export buying perspective now some
of you mentioned this coin whoa
okay this is pretty much what I think if
I'm honest with you why in a Range we
had a deviation here
um I do think that is very likely that
we come again to the range lows and
print a deviation uh also to the
downside okay so I think that this coin
should probably drop below 10 cents okay
maybe around 0.9
um from there I think that would be the
perfect buying opportunity and again
remember that I think this because I
think that the total three is gonna
happen another like lower uh if it
doesn't happen then who wouldn't make a
new a new level right so keep the in
your mind because uh it's normal that
you disagree with me but again this is
what I think I think it's gonna have a
new uh leg lower and because of that
thing this coin is probably gonna go
below the range lows okay before going
higher uh so that's what I think of this
coin then you also mentioned uh compound
I think it's called Uh I see pretty much
the same thing okay you have your range
okay you go down you go up down up down
up and this is just some kind of
consolidation so
um other thing that this coin
has something quite uh important and it
is
okay that's a liquidity pool so data
Target in my opinion for the next bull
market
and if it drops
again to the range lows
okay
then from here
all the way to the liquidity pull up
there that would be
uh times 25 a 25x I mean that would be
amazing okay so that's what I'm looking
for this coin I think I'm gonna revisit
probably the rain slows again uh let's
continue
let's check this coin
a data okay same thing you know you're
in a Range it goes down it goes up it
goes down you're also testing the weekly
50 MMS resistance
um for the simple fact that I'm
expecting a new low in the 2003 then I
think that we're probably gonna come
again to the range lows and very likely
even print a new low okay before coming
back up all right so that's what I think
for this coin maybe it goes to three
cents okay right now almost a six cents
so that would be maybe a forty percent
drop
let's continue
cardano Ada
same thing all right guys uh range
deviation to the upside
okay and you are the range loss is
looking very something I like to you and
I've also mentioned before that
my potential bison for this coin is
going to be this liquidity pool over
here because I think we're working
towards it we've already filled uh
pretty much half of it we made a new a
new low and we talked about idea also uh
I think I made a video of Carolina three
months ago and we were mentioning the
Avenue low he got there but I even think
that's gonna go lower because in that
video we were also mentioned in this
target over here okay so around 18 cents
do I think we'll get there
I do I think it's likely that cardano
maybe it takes another drop here
okay before coming back up so that's
what I think for cardan I think we're
probably gonna come to zero eighteen
nothing has changed same projection that
I had three months ago
let's continue uh some moral coins ocean
another artificial intelligence coin
that I'm probably gonna buy this one is
quite interesting because it puts
together Big Data with uh artificial
intelligence so it's something that I'm
looking into okay
um you were here in inside this range
then you have the breakout but if you
notice now price is bleeding slowly it's
making lower highs
and lower lows okay so it's very likely
that we have a lower
so it's very likely that we continue
bleeding and slowly while right now
below the 50 I mean the weekly time
frame but sign get back into the range
okay and maybe go again towards either
the mid range here
okay around 20 cents or 15 cents that's
those two will be my buy zones for for
ocean okay
um quite no I like to use quite
aggressive
what I'm expecting okay we're talking
about 40 drop or a 50 drop but I I
believe we're probably gonna see that
okay uh so that's what I think for ocean
now if we check
injective many of you mentioned this
coin
I accept this one almost for the end
because this coin is behaving very
different than the other coins that we
talked about there is no range here as
you can see okay but there is a
beautiful WB formation here
check that out then goes up you had the
retreat to the weekly 50ma textbook
perfect and then another uh a new high
okay
in this uh trend
so beautiful pattern he behaved in terms
of price action and personally I think
that Bitcoin is Gonna Come to test again
the quickly 50ma right now it's at
7.25 on the weekly 50 minutes at 5.67 so
that would be already uh
let me tell you that will be already
around 15 drop or 20 drop I think we'll
get there
if I'm honest with you okay and then
from here let's see how it reacts
because this coin is true that he moves
different than the rest of the of the
alcohol market so if we go to the weekly
50ma which I think we will then
let's see what it does because women see
another uh reaction from here I make a
new high or if we fall below the weekly
50ma then I want you to pay attention to
this because that would signal that you
should wait for a retest as resistance
of the of this 50ma
and then you're gonna go again to uh the
base of this W formation dates around
this level
of three dollars
um that also goes together
with the base of this
W bottom here well not the base okay but
you guys know what I mean the breakout
and also with this long week over here
because yes there is a long week over
here okay so that's what I think
I think that something like that that
puts together with the 50 of the week
around three dollars
it's very likely uh if we again only if
we fall below the weekly 50ma and we
tested that as resistance otherwise you
still have the possibility of coming to
the 50ma test it as support and have a
new uh hi I'm not dismissing the idea
because this coin must
quite different okay
so another some of you asked for this
coin so uh I hope that you're happy now
uh Litecoin
okay this another coin the is looking
quite strange compared to the other uh
alkoons you had the halvin uh but to be
honest I think the Halloween was around
here and or or some somewhere like yeah
and price has only doomed since then
okay I have here to
two setups
I have one for the short term and one
for the midterm so for the short term go
to the Daily time frame
we have this week over here
that it hasn't been filled so and you
also have here a liquidity pool that
hasn't been retraced so I think that
maybe you see here
somewhere consolidation even on a small
pump but price should eventually come
lower to fill this week and also to
retrace this liquidity pool over here
okay so that will take you to around
50.51 52 dollars and for the midterm
I do think that it's very likely that we
come again to this lows sorry let me use
this
this line so it's not wonky line okay I
think it's likely that we come to this
lows of around 47 48 dollars and then if
we drop from here if we lose this level
then the next level would be thirty
dollars because if we go to the weekly
time frame sorry to the monthly time
frame
you go here you go yourself a week and
that will be the 50 of the week okay so
basically
I think that Litecoin is gonna go to
fifty dollars forty seven forty eight
dollars okay to that zone and if we lose
this Zone
then get ready because something you're
gonna be able to buy a 30 okay so two
bison's depending on how it behaves
that's the first one if it holds about
fear then you come back here if we lose
this Zone then you can buy lower here
okay so that's my analysis for Litecoin
uh let's continue
what's the next coin arbitrim
r usdt
this coin I mean guys how are you going
to charge this this is the weekly time
frame look and and see how it looks it's
difficult to start this okay but
if I'm honest with you uh
uh I mean it's difficult to chat but I
think we're gonna probably break below
this low here okay that's your low but
because I'm thinking that there is going
to be another letdown in balcony market
then arbit room should drop lower
um it's difficult to tell okay I could
tell you 75 cents 80 cents I don't know
I don't know it could be high I could be
lower because we don't have much history
in the chart to tell you where there are
potential uh Bisons okay but I think
we're gonna probably come below here
um probably to around 80 cents but could
be again Lower uh that's what I think um
this I don't know how much of a drop
this would be
around 20 again it could be true it
could be low I don't know okay we'll
continue charting this coin but uh if
the the technology looks good
so this might be one of the coins that
I'm also gonna look for uh buying for an
export market so that's pretty much
everything guys uh I'm sorry that the
video was so long but I wanted to do
another update of the previous 12 alkins
and then add these 10 nual coins okay so
hope that you enjoyed hope that I
covered your all coins if I if I haven't
um do you still want me to charge other
alcohols please let me know in the
comments and we might see a part three
this might turn into some kind of
Trilogy like Lord of the Rings so thank
you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon